- I was never raised to, uh, be a racist.
It was never a part of my
life until I was in prison.
It was born out of pure necessity.
You have to change who you are.
When you come into jail,
you come into prison,
you've got your white gangs.
You've got your black gangs.
If you step outside of that,
you're not only gonna have one enemy,
you're gonna have two.
The tattoo for me was
definitely like a shield.
The day I got released, I was
determined not to just give up
and say, "That's who I am."
And I realized that I can change this.
My name is Dave Cutlip,
and we run Redemption Ink.
I have been tattooing for over 20 years.
We help people get a second chance
by removing racist and
gang tattoos for free.
We started about six months ago.
I've done 16 coverups now.
The demand for this,
to be honest with you,
it's overwhelming.
I'm gonna try and do it
at least once a week,
either here or at conventions
until I just can't tattoo anymore.
People are just going
full-bore trying to get help.
And most of them, I'd have to
say, they're already moved on.
They just still have the tattoos
that are holding them back.
Like, I'm glad that I have a talent
that I can help somebody.
Those people deserve the
pat on the back, not me.
They did what they needed
to do to change their lives.
- At the end of the day,
I didn't want my daughter
picking up on that message.
I didn't want my daughter thinking
like that type of thinking is right.
Or asking me where I
got it or why I got it.
She doesn't have to see any of that.
And I'm just like grateful
for that every day
is that she never had to
see me as that person.